[Musica]
che cosa ci riveleranno le neuroscienze
applicate sul futuro del pensiero umano
quando ho cominciato a riflettere su che
cosa avrei voluto raccontare su questo
tema
l'immagine esatta che si visualizzata
nel mio cervello è quella che vedete le
mie spalle
ovvero il buio totale che è più o meno
quello che si prova 10 secondi prima di
uscire su questo palco bagni si è aperto
uno spiraglio
perché chi come me è cresciuto negli
anni 70 ha sempre associato il futuro
dell'umanità e dell'intelligenza
artificiale ai robot umanoidi a questi
essere dilata neanche tanto belli che
avrebbero rappresentato magicamente
l'esito del pensiero umano in qualcosa
di superiore
arrivato lì mi sono di nuovo perso non
riuscivo a trovare lo spiraglio per
capire che cosa c'entrasse questa cosa
dei robot con il mio lavoro attuale loro
ho consultato il mio filosofo di
riferimento che si chiama ghennadi
pietro ubiali a 8 anni e per mia fortuna
vive con me perché mio figlio è un
filosofo italo russo che ancora non è
così famoso
a un certo punto mentre io mi batto in
questo groviglio di pensieri lui viene
da me mi guarda con una certa pietà e io
gli dico senti dna di mi devi aiutare ma
noi nel futuro dell'umanità che cos'è
che insegneremo ai robot e lui senza la
minima esitazione mi dice le buone
maniere
poi prende e se ne va perché ovviamente
un bambino di 8 anni a una spande
attenzione di una zanzara e quindi mi
abbandona io di nuovo rimango solo con
me stesso ma mi si è accesa un'altra
luce
sì perché se quello che insegneremo ai
robot se la parte essenziale del
pensiero umano che vogliamo trasferire i
robot fosse veramente come dice il mio
filosofo di riferimento l'empatia le
buone maniere
suppongono che voi sappiate leggere in
anticipo i sentimenti del vostro
interlocutore ci ho visto un
collegamento
io ho un grande privilegio sono co
founder e amministratore di un'azienda
che tutti i giorni si occupa di
neuroscienze applicate
immaginate un azienda che passa il suo
tempo in giro per il mondo a raccogliere
dati neurologici e i suoi esseri umani
che fanno esperienze nella vita reale
guidare un'auto prendono un aereo vanno
in un bosco mangiare un piatto e io ho
una poltrona di prima fila strepitosa
l'inghippo nasce dal fatto che io sono
laureata in filosofia
quindi sono co founder di un'azienda che
fa neuroscienza e non capisco niente di
neuroscienza non è esattamente così
però sono l'unico filosofo nella stanza
è un vantaggio o uno svantaggio quando
mio figlio mi dice che secondo lui il
futuro dell'intelligenza artificiale e
del pensiero umano è il trasferimento
della capacità empatica e della capacità
umana di provare emozione
improvvisamente mi rendo conto che la
poltrona su cui io sono seduto è una
poltrona privilegiata perché ho il posto
in prima fila su quello che durante la
sua gloriosa carriera alan turing a un
certo punto postula quando dice dalla
materia
nasce la coscienza
pensate io sto seduto tutti i giorni in
prima fila e guardo le neuroscienze
applicate che misurano potrei allungare
la mano a mettere il dito non me lo
fanno fare ma che non hanno stima di me
in azienda però potrei allungare la mano
e toccare con un dito
quel luogo misterioso del nostro
cervello in cui dalla materia nasce
attraverso un'attività chimica elettrica
quello che noi chiamiamo la coscienza il
pensiero
finalmente cominciamo a intravedere il
senso profondo del mio guru ghennadi
perché mi sono reso conto che forse
quello che le neuroscienze applicate che
noi portiamo in giro per tutto il
pianeta
oggi potevano insegnarci sul futuro del
pensiero degli uomini era qualcosa di
veramente nuovo da raccontarvi allora
entusiasta di questa trovata ho
condiviso questo pensiero con i
neuroscienziati del nostro team destando
grande sconforto perché quando mi sono
rivolto i neuroscienziati del nostro
team ha detto bene ma allora che cosa
stiamo capendo di questo ammasso
complesso che secondo gli ultimi
articoli della letteratura
neuroscientifica in grado di computare
come un computer quantico a 68
dimensioni ragazzi ci devo andare su un
palco a raccontare al mondo attraverso
teteks che cosa tiriamo fuori da lì
sull'essenza della del pensiero umano e
questi ma network sostanzialmente nulla
denso mario ha allora per dimostrare che
i soldi dei miei genitori non erano
andati completamente sprecati sono
tornata quella poltrona di cui vi
parlavo mi sono cioè domandato se in
realtà il problema di fondo non fosse
che quando voi misurate la complessa
attività né una elettrica di
quell'ammasso assolutamente intricato i
tessuti dice l'unione chiamateli come
volete
quando voi siete lì estate misurando
quello forse spiegare come quello
funzione come da quella materia diceva
turi si origina il vostro pensiero
richiede qualcosa di diverso allora
facendo ricorso ai soldi ben spesi dei
miei genitori mi sono rivolto a questo
signore che è un altro mio filosofo di
riferimento chino più vecchio
con questo potrei averlo come nonno
l'altro e mio figlio
questo signore si chiama martin
heidegger per chi a crisi di insonnia è
una cura ideale seriamente parlando è un
grande filosofo del novecento un uomo
molto controverso ma l'aiuto che gli
chiediamo oggi per figurarci come le
neuroscienze applicate possono
insegnarci qualcosa sulla natura del
futuro del nostro pensiero ci viene da
una sua rarissima e divertentissima
intervista del 1954 che trovate su
youtube si interessa va in televisione
alla fine di una carriera lunghissima
brillante ha scritto libri che
richiedono altri libri per essere
interpretati e dice una cosa che passa
ovviamente sotto un silenzio assordante
dice ci sono due tipi di pensiero umano
un pensiero è il pensiero cosiddetto
degli enti prefill oso fi hanno questa
difficoltà parlar chiaro il pensiero
degli enti ci dice heidegger sarebbe il
pensiero che serve a capire le cose
la meccanica delle cose lui la associa
il pensiero scientifico tecnologico
invece se questa roba qui la sun fra
tutti gli esseri umani sono capaci tutti
non dimenticatevi che qui stiamo
parlando per esempio di intelligenza
artificiale
forse una lampadina già si sta
accendendo il pensiero degli enti le
regole con cui operare sulle cose è un
pensiero che è facile da insegnare a una
macchina
poi però siccome hai legare un po sadico
e questo chi ha studiato filosofia lo sa
bene basta fare un esame di ermeneutica
filosofica aggiunge con grande no chance
che c'è un secondo tipo di pensiero e
lui dice guardate questo pensiero
questo pensiero è ben più difficile da
praticare lo praticano in pochissimi tra
tutti gli esseri umani pensate un po
questo che dice sta roba in televisione
no
e dice quest'altro pensiero è il
pensiero
delle essenze il pensiero delle essenze
il pensiero che serve a comprendere il
senso delle cose già così non è proprio
la cosa palatabile giusto per rendere le
cose un po più complicate però abbiate
pazienza con me poi lo mettiamo lì lo
riprendiamo tra qualche minuto il buon
heidegger dice ecco questo tipo di
pensiero anche vi sto raccontando ora
quello delle spese è un pensiero poetico
lasciamola lei venite a fare una
passeggiata con me ricordatevi che ci
sono due tipi di pensiero sposate la
tesi a i the year jana
immaginate di essere in montagna
immaginate per vostra sfortuna di avere
dormito in un bellissimo chalet di cirò
un bosco con un team di neuroscienziati
vi svegliate alla mattina vi vestite per
fare una passeggiata comoda e noi li
mettiamo in testa un
elettroencefalogramma e decidiamo di
registrare tutta vostra attività
neurologica mentre fate questa
passeggiata uscite vi investe l'aria
fresca avete le dita ancora un po
intirizzite la rugiada del mattino e sui
prati intorno a voi c'è un sentiero che
porta al bosco avanti i 100 metri e
camminando sentite rumore della ghiaia
sotto i vostri scarponcino il sole sta
sorgendo il cielo è già chiaro voi vi
avviate quando entrate nel bosco come
spesso accade in montagna c'è una
leggera inversione termica nel bosco v
fa un po più caldo i rumori si
attutiscono lievemente ma i vostri sensi
improvvisamente sembrano misurare tutto
meglio e di più
il rumore sotto i piedi è cambiato
perché ci sono delle foglie secche degli
aghi nell'aria ci sono aromi sprigionati
dalle resine tra le piante le dita si
sono scaldate la vostra pelle comincia a
sudare leggermente abbassate l'assist e
la giacca i primi uccelli del mattino
agi
dai rami ne sentite il suono in fruscio
vi sentite cinguettare più avanti sul
sentiero un animale attraverso voi non
avete capito quale ma avete capito che
non è pericoloso quindi se vuoi tornaste
da questa passeggiata
diciamo dopo un'oretta e la nostra
equipe trasferisse i dati che è
registrato per cominciare ad esaminarli
che cosa vedremo vedremo che tutto
quello che è accaduto nel vostro
cervello nell'arco di quella esperienza
e badate bene questo era un esempio
avrei potuto parlarvi di un qualunque
esperienza
voi state facendo compresa quella che
fate ora ascoltando bene avremmo visto
una cosa molto interessante cioè che nel
coacervo di dati che noi abbiamo
raccolto sul vostro cervello ce n'è una
parte che si origina dalla corteccia
superiore che si occupano dei processi
cognitivi razionali linguistici quello
che voi nella vostra abitudine
quotidiana tendete a pensare sia il
vostro pensiero a ami vedere cosa ho
pensato è un po più complicato ed è così
perché il nostro team quando io ho detto
ragazzi ma cosa stiamo scoprendo sul
pensiero profondo
mi hanno risposto nulla in realtà quello
che loro vogliono dire che noi stiamo
entrando in una nuova era
perché sotto la corteccia di quei
pensieri ci stavamo un'altra categoria
di pensiero che è una risposta profonda
istintiva non controllata che il vostro
cervello a a qualunque stimolo esterno
aspettate ancora meglio di così diventa
ancora meglio di così
il vostro cervello risponde in maniera
diversa a seconda della natura degli
stimoli dell'ambiente che lo circonda
secondo un principio che sembra più lo
studiamo sembra assomigliare a quello
che in fisica quantistica viene chiamato
entanglement nel principio dell'ente in
gola mentre la fisica quantistica dice
che se noi separiamo due particelle
subatomiche provenienti dallo stesso
atomo e ne vendiamo un a ginevra e una
londra
quando imprimeremo lo spin ad una delle
due
l'altra istantaneamente subirà lo stesso
spiega questa misteriosa
interconnessione adesso prendete le
trasferitela sul rapporto tra il vostro
cervello che incidentalmente vorrei
ricordarvi è fatto della stessa identica
materia di cui ha fatto tutto l'universo
capi circonda e quell'universo e allora
forse quello che noi stiamo scoprendo
con le neuroscienze applicate ogni
giorno non è conclusivo non è facile non
è lineare e richiede un salto di
paradigma per tutti gli ultimi trecento
anni almeno della nostra storia
noi abbiamo salito una scala per andare
in alto ci sembrava che il pensiero
umano il futuro del pensiero umano
dovesse essere il futuro radioso della
logica più raffinata della
cristallizzazione dei migliori principi
e salivamo questa scala e poi un certo
punto arriva uno come vite in style che
dice i ragazzi abbiamo costruito una
scala favolosa peccato che quando siamo
stati in alto la la scala e cascate non
riusciamo più a tornare giù poi arriva
un altro pazzo fischiava gu del
matematico amico di einstein einstein
disse io vado a lavorare a piedi per mio
casa mia all'ufficio di stanford solo
per poter camminare insieme a ge tel
quindi se einstein aveva questa stima di
google potremmo dargli retta pro 2
minuti crede a un certo punto posso la
teoria il teorema dell'incompletezza
dice cioè che il sistema matematico non
è autosufficiente non è concluso ha
bisogno di un modello esterno che stare
in piedi
ma cosa c'entra questo con le
neuroscienze con una c'entra questo col
nonno heidegger c'entra tantissimo
c'entra tantissimo perché quello che noi
stiamo scoprendo non è su non è il
pensiero che ci arrabbattiamo tutti a
ragionare di trasferire nelle macchine
quello del pensiero degli enti se il
buon vecchio ed è che fosse ancora vivo
ci darebbe uno scappellotto ci dirà
prima non hai capito niente
quella il pensiero degli enti e roba
facile
i robot possono già sembra
tra un'automobile o far volare un aereo
anche se la idea non vi piace molto ma
che cos'è che ci rende umani e la parte
al pensiero che dobbiamo riscoprire non
sarà per caso che la parte del pensiero
che dobbiamo riscoprire sta giù ma non è
un gioco ali tativo non sarà per caso
che la parte il pensiero che dobbiamo
veramente riscoprire come umana e quella
risposta profonda istintiva emotiva
mnemonica biologica tanto potete usare
tutti gli aggettivi che volete ma finché
non fate il salto di paradigma
finché non girate il tavolo non lo
vedrete mai nella sua interezza con la
neuroscienza applicata noi stiamo
scoprendo solo poco questo intricato
rapporto di interconnessione tra come il
nostro cervello risponde all universo e
quello che quello universale e più
andiamo avanti e più lo scopriamo e per
scopriamo che se noi leggiamo essere
umane in trasparenza
siccome lui è fatto dell'universo che
c'è intorno
quel pensiero che rispecchia l'universo
non richiede uno sforzo cognitivo
adesso avete capito perché heidegger
dice che quell altro tipo di pensiero e
poetico perché quando dice poetico lui
vuole dire lo dice in un altro suo libro
la verità di una cosa succede nella mia
testa con un raggio di sole entra in una
radura il nostro lavoro di esseri umani
nella neuroscienza applicata si sta
rivelando profondamente filosofico
perché ci sta costringendo a scoprire
un'interconnessione per la quale non è
sufficiente la neuroscienza non è
sufficiente il paradigma della
psicologia cognitiva non è sufficiente
la fisica quantistica
nessuna delle discipline da sola sarà
sufficiente a capire qualcosa in più ea
gettare una luce
eppure l'appello che io vorrei farvi
sulla base del lavoro che noi facciamo
quotidianamente è prima di tutto un
appello umano
andando via da qui la mia preghiera e la
preghiera di ricordarvi
che prima di porci il problema di cose
insegneremo ai robot di cosa
trasferiremo sulle macchine di quale
sarà il futuro della meravigliosa e
mirabolante intelligenza artificiale non
sarebbe affatto male se ci focalizziamo
su quello che è il nostro pensiero umano
si accetta sta uscendo da qui intendo
vialetto stasera e spegnendo la luce non
voglio rovinarvi la serata e chiudendo
gli occhi che forse nel vostro cervello
può succedere un miracolo o ogni istante
della vostra vita
il vostro cervello risponde in maniera
sincrona al mondo dell'universo che vi
circondano
e sapete qual è la notizia
drammaticamente importante che se voi
preservare the salverete questa idea di
quello che siete come esseri umani
dovrete per forza salvare l'universo che
vi circonda perché se quell universo
sarà salvato e sarà integro integra sarà
la vostra parte più umana nel salvare
voi stessi voi salverete il mondo che vi
circonda però dovete fare una
rivoluzione una rivoluzione che
paradossalmente sta avvenendo dal mondo
delle neuroscienze da una di quelle
discipline che viene considerata più
scientifiche in assoluto e io penso che
questo giorno non sia così lontano penso
che questo giorno arriverà penso che gli
esseri umani saranno in grado di
recuperare questa dimensione del loro
pensiero profondo e quando lo faranno un
robot a cui nel frattempo avranno
insegnato le buone maniere
probabilmente ci offrirà un ottimo drink
grazie
[Applauso]